dirais que je parie bonsoir bonsoir oui
effectivement le ministre dit parmi les
sept pouces et de cas qu'on voit il ya
beaucoup de jeunes comment avant de
parler des tests rapides le passé
l'essentiel de mon propos mais les la
vaccination chez les jeunes on est
rendus ou pis comment ces vols
ont dû la honda de ce matin que j'ai pas
encore validé riche de la journée 1 45%
de d2 nos jeunes partout au québec qui
en soit rendez vous ou bien la dose a
été administrée et on voit certaines
différences à la grandeur du québec mais
parce que les stratégies sont différents
mais encore jeune il était très active
très heureux du travail dans les
établissements de santé et savait sauf
on présente ce qu'un des régions que
vous inquiète cadets région viendront
c'est très très bon
c'est eux qui est stratégique est
différent c'est drôle à dire mais les
éclés région bousculer ou ce qu'on
espérons envers m on se présente partout
dans les écoles il ya pour lui
d'entendre un exemple au niveau des
autobus et de sète hérault des chiffres
tabary parce qu'on a les chefs seulement
lorsque les habitations de bach cei ont
été faits et que moi je regarde ça
heureuse comme ça se parle présent ok
pour éviter que des jeunes qui ont la
cote des symptômes de coved et qui ont
la coved eux retournent dans la classe
puis qu'on doive fermer éventuellement
des classes etc il ya les fameux tests
rapides les passions sur un an et demi
qu'on en parle qu'on les voit pas à quel
moment et lolë vous dis aujourd'hui que
les parents vont recevoir cinq tests les
parents qui ont des écoliers on avait
dit ça pour les cp 1 là les gens
attendent encore quand les gens auront
les petites boîtes
bon petit bois plus de représenter ses
seins et ses rites droite en question au
niveau des services de garde
effectivement l'annoncé les toutes les
rives les tests sont ce tribut et dans
les cci cieux c'est là les arrangements
se font entre les services de garde et
les établissements de santé pour les
écoles d'art au jour par des palettes
sont envoyés au niveau des sortes de
sorties scolaires pour distribution dans
les écoles dont on ne choisit certaines
régions notamment l montréal montérégie
laval parce qu'on voit que plus de corps
justement positifs et tout ça est bien
sûr lié à la réception ou livraison de
descente et de savon mon lit vraiment
confiant que les pins l'addition pour
reprendre votre expression les palettes
ils sont où mais il arrive federel
arrive au dépôt provincial et on les
livre de face et la même journée même au
niveau des sens de sa vie scolaire ok
mais son radio c'est sur ma question
sont rendus houle
soit dans les camions ou soit dans
l'essor des services scolaires et la
distribution au niveau des écoles va
débuter demain ok c'est ça donc demain
au cours des prochains jours sa part et
l'objectif c'est pour les enfants mais
ce pari c'est pas pour mettons gers où
j'ai une petite fille à l'école c'est
pas pour moi si je vais dans un souper
avec des amis c'est destiné aux enfants
la grande stratégie là c'est qu'on vise
les sur des gardes en premier comme on
laisse les gens ne sont pas vaccinés
deuxième phase des écoles primaires
parce que justement on est en voie de
les vacciner pour reçu leur deuxième
dose et je vais vous dire que je
travaille fort m'apprenez stratégie
populationnelle lorsque les tests
disponibles au niveau de la population
et ça c'est un coup et devrait être
capable de vous faire certaines annonces
et bien bon mais dont le 17 décembre
vendredi prochain et beaucoup de gens
qui ont des rassemblements dans des
restaurants ou dans des bons pendant
s'est pas encore 20 dans les maisons ça
c'est le 23 décembre en vue de ces
rassemblements d'adultes est ce que ça
sera arriver d'ici dix jours pour tout
le monde
il devrait en avoir d'arrivées au québec
selon les raisons j'ai eu des
discussions quelqu un m a fédéré tantôt
qui ne donne et des projections de
livraison oui on voyait arriver mais
permettez moi je te dis que les tests
rapides ça va être un outil dans notre
stratégie de se protéger mais au fait de
la fièvre qui ont eu des symptômes ne
cohabitent pas d'aller dans un parfait
dans une famille
c'était la même chose l'an passé les
autres années avant je pense le gros bon
sens doit demeurer une voix un symptôme
de pays de bien se protéger parce que
les tests rapides malheureusement
ne changeront pas c'était
vraiment important de bien gérer le
second c'est cette façon alors
attendez mais si notre enfant des légers
symptômes un petit lait qui colle pas de
fièvre est tout simple on veut par
acquis de conscience avoir avoir le
coeur net c'était cela vont nous aider
si on peut les recevoir à la maison vous
deviez de demain ça commence à être
distribué lundi et pour la population
générale au cours de la semaine
prochaine j'ai bien compris ou pour la
semaine prochaine j'aurai des nouvelles
pour la population générale ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui où nos enceintes y
avait eu égard aux écoles primaires
la voie est tracée on y entend
distribuer ses cadeaux de tests rapides
et pour la population générale on aura
des honoraires des annonces bientôt pour
les deux bleus vacciner je vous laisse
là tu me séparer on dit par contre que
pour les deux vacciner si on attrape la
coved comme la charge virale est plus
faible que c'était cela sont moins
fiables c'est ce qu'on vous explique
russie
mais nous on vous encourage et là encore
une fois des gens symptomatique est laid
le tesla tests rapides encore une fois
c'est celle et l'été sont moins précis
et un bon thé spécial qu'on doit se
déplacer dans un centre de dépistage
avec encore une fois un outil à utiliser
votre gros bon sens par rapport à ça
pour bien protéger l'environnement et
c'est de cette façon alors
oui ça c'est la nouvelle formule
apprendre à vivre effectivement et même
montré la boîte comme on le fait le test
oh écoutez je suis vraiment pas la
meilleure personne pour
moi
c'est un c'est un écouvillon au niveau 2
au niveau du nez il ya encore les
insultes s'en sort bien donné
l'utilisation facile et il part alors on
pouvait le faire
d'abord là débute très bien daniel paris
directeur de la campagne de vaccination
merci beaucoup de gens parlent en direct
merci bonsoir et au revoir